Good morning, Hank; it's Monday, January 22nd.
Thank you for this shirt. I love this shirt,
and it is also an excellent motivator to continue
losing weight. It's a little tight!
Seriously it's my favorite shirt out of all
the shirts I've ever owned. I was planning
on starting the survey today, but unfortunately
that's gonna have to wait until Wednesday.
Hank, as you know I write books for teenagers,
and the biggest award in the world of books
for teenagers is this thing called the Printz
Award, which is given out every year for literary
excellence. Last night I received a call from
the Printz Committee saying that my new book,
An Abundance of Katherines, has been awarded
a Printz Honor for 2007. So that was nice
and really, really unexpected.
Sarah didn't pick up the camera right when
they called, but she picked it up shortly
after. As a bonus you're about to hear the
voice of the Yeti.
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, are you serious?
Really? Hahahaha! They keep saying, they keep
saying, "We're fugging serious." (laughter)
I can't believe it! Oh my God! Really? Wow!
Wow!
Oh my God, guys, I cannot, I can't believe
this. Thank you guys so much, tha- thi- Wow.
(The Yeti): This is John's real Happy Dance.
(John): I'm just, like, all flustered. I hope
they're home.
(The Yeti): They have cells.
(John): I don't wanna, I don't want to leave
it in a message.
(The Yeti): No, don't leave a message.
(John): Hi, it's John, Katherines got a Printz
Honor. Katherines is one of the runners up
for the Printz Awards; it gets the silver
medal on it. I know! No, I'm serious. I can't
believe it. Yeah, it's funny because we're
recording it for the video blog, so it'll
be hilarious on the blog. No I'm not shitting
you, I, I, I am also, I am also surprised.
Hahaha. Oh my God, I can't believe it. Ahh.
No the committee, yeah the committee called
me, they were very nice. They wouldn't tell
me who won, though, haha. Yeah, I can't believe
it, so, pretty, pretty amazing, so yeah.
And finally Hank, I'd like to say thank you
for the lady, lady, lady, lady, lady, lady,
lady, John Green song which is probably the
nicest thing that anyone has ever done for
me in my whole entire life.
And by nice, I mean hilariously mean. Why
is it that I equate niceness and hilarious
meanness? Oh, right, it's from growing up
in our family. I'll see you tomorrow.